to infinity
and beyond
hello friends and welcome back to our
countdown of animated films this time
we're covering pixar's top 10. may the
best monster win
i plan to
we are on in seven
six
five
four
three
two
when disney released pixar's toy story
as an alternative to traditional 2d
animated features in 1995 could the
studio have predicted that it would
instead set the gold standard for
theatrical cartoons for decades to come
i mean the slide from peak disney
renaissance had only just begun and
pixar was up until that point a studio
that only made commercials and shorts
pixar's follow-up took three years to
hit theaters and although a bug's life
is looked back on in the canon as a
minor effort everyone in 1998 rushed out
to see it and it again ended up grossing
more than disney's hercules and mulan
1999's toy story 2 was a cultural event
and established pixar as the one to take
animation to the highest heights in the
new century what followed was a then
unprecedented run of certified fresh
hits and box office smashes from
monsters inc and finding nemo to the
incredibles wall-e and up
2011's cars 2 broke the streak with
pixar's first rotten film and the studio
has since spent the past decade
oscillating between returning to the
sequel and pulling up original property
closing out with toy story 4.
for 2020 onward was pulled from theaters
due to the pandemic while seoul went
straight to disney plus in hopes of
salvaging a year of chaos so right now
we're gonna take a look back at the past
25 years ranking all pixar movies by
tomato meter
[Music]
number 10 ratatouille
remy a resident of paris appreciates
good food and is quite a sophisticated
palette he would love to become a chef
so he can create and enjoy culinary
masterpieces to his heart's delight the
only problem is remy is a rat when he
winds up in the sewer beneath one of
paris's finest restaurants the rodent
gourmet finds himself ideally placed to
realize his dream starring patton oswald
ian holm lou romano and directed by brad
bird and jan pinkava critics say fast
paced and stunningly animated
ratatouille adds another delightfully
entertaining entry and a rather unlikely
hero to the pixar canon don't watch this
one while you're hungry
what are you waiting for is this gonna
become a regular thing with you know how
to fix it this is your chance
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
number nine the incredibles
in this lotted pixar animated film
married superheroes mr incredible and
elastigirl are forced to assume mundane
lives as bob and helen parr after all
super-powered activities have been
banned by the government
while mr incredible loves his wife and
kids he longs to return to a life of
adventure and he gets a chance when
summoned to an island to battle an
out-of-control robot soon mr incredible
is in trouble and it's up to his family
to save him starring craig t nelson
holly hunter samuel l jackson and
directed by brad bird critics say
bringing loads of wit and tons of fun to
the animated superhero genre the
incredibles easily lives up to its name
but also low-key edna e-mode needs her
own spin-off just throwing that out
there i know you're there little miss
disappear
[Music]
you can't hide from me
[Music]
there you are
[Music]
[Applause]
stop
[Music]
[Music]
despite his family's generation's old
band on music young miguel dreams of
becoming an accomplished musician like
his idol ernesto de la cruz
desperate to prove his talent miguel
finds himself in the stunning and
colorful land of the dead
after meeting a charming trickster named
hector the two new friends embark on an
extraordinary journey to unlock the real
story behind miguel's family history
starring anthony gonzalez gael garcia
bernal benjamin bratt and directed by
lee unkrich critics say coco's rich
visual pleasures are matched by a
thoughtful narrative that takes a
family-friendly and deeply affecting
approach to questions of culture family
life and death coco also takes home the
prize for making grown men cry
next family please
[Music]
oh your photos are in your son sofrinda
have a great visit
and remember to return before sunrise
enjoy your visit next
your photos on your dentist brenda enjoy
your visit
next
yes it is i frida kahlo shall we skip
the scanner i'm on so many of friends
it'll just overwhelm your blinky thingy
oh shoot looks like no one put up your
photo free them okay when i say that was
friday just now that
that was a lie and i apologize for doing
that no photo no friends uh no crossing
the bridge you know what i'm just gonna
zip right over you won't even know i'm
gone
[Music]
number seven toy story 4.
woody buzz lightyear and the rest of the
gang embark on a road trip with bonnie
and a new toy named forky the
adventurous journey turns into an
unexpected reunion as woody's slight
detour leads him to his long lost friend
beau peep
as woody and bo discuss the old days
they soon start to realize that they're
worlds apart when it comes to what they
want from life as a toy
starring tom hanks tim allen tony hale
annie potts and directed by josh cooley
critics say heartwarming funny and
beautifully animated toy story 4 manages
the unlikely feat of extending and
perhaps concluding a practically perfect
animated saga
woody how'd you find me
i found him hi wait it's an actual fork
bus the dummies are gone what
where'd they go
[Music]
okay we could go now no i need to find
my girl hello woody hi bo where are my
sheep yeah look what he found me take
the bunny i'm too cute to die
[Music]
woody i just want to talk yeah with my
voice box
[Music]
[Music]
drop it
number six up carl frederickson a 78
year old balloon salesman is about to
fulfill a lifelong dream tying thousands
of balloons to his house he flies away
to the south american wilderness but
curmudgeonly carl's worst nightmare
comes true when he discovers a little
boy named russell is a stowaway aboard
the balloon-powered house starring ed
asner christopher plummer jordan nagai
and directed by pete doctor and bob
peterson critics say this film is an
exciting funny and poignant adventure up
offers an impeccably crafted story told
with wit and arranged with depth as well
as yet another visual pixar tree and if
you aren't crying in the first couple
minutes of up well that may be weird
what is that thing it's a sniper
there's no such thing as a sniper what
you said
[Music]
careful russell hey look mr matterson is
like sweetie
get out of here
it's okay
mr frederickson is nice kevin yeah
that's his name i just gave him
feed
number five toy story three
with their beloved andy preparing to
leave for college woody buzz lightyear
jessie and the rest of the toys find
themselves headed for the attic but
mistakenly wind up on the curb with the
trash
woody's quick thinking saves the gang
but all but would he end up being
donated to a daycare center
unfortunately the uncontrollable kids do
not play nice so woody and the gang make
plans for a great escape
starring tom hanks tim allen joan cusack
and directed by lee unkrich critics say
deathly blending comedy adventure and
honest emotion toy story 3 is a rare
second sequel that really works it's
also the film that loki brought my
favorite pixar couple to life barbie and
ken
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
number four inside out
riley is a happy hockey loving 11 year
old midwestern girl but her world turns
upside down when she and her parents
move to san francisco
riley's emotions led by joy try to guide
her through this difficult life-changing
event however the stress of the move
brings sadness to the forefront when joy
and sadness are inadvertently swept into
the far reaches of riley's mind the only
emotions left in headquarters are anger
fear and disgust starring amy poehler
phyllis smith bill hader lewis black
mindy kaling and directed by pete doctor
critics say inventive gorgeously
animated and powerfully moving inside
out is another outstanding addition to
the pixar library of modern animated
classics i will take you but not you oh
my kitty i can't leave you
hello
wait hey wait
[Music]
excuse me
uh i was i was looking for um diversion
sucker
wait i know you no you don't i get that
a lot
i look like a lot of people no no i do
riley's imaginary friend you really do
know me of course riley loves playing
with you you two are best friends oh oh
you wouldn't know we're trying to get
back to headquarters headquarters you
guys are from headquarters well yeah
i'm joy this is sadness your joy the joy
mm-hmm well what the heck you doing out
here that's a good question you want to
answer that sadness oh without you i
don't ever be happy we can't have that
we got to get you back uh i'll tell you
follow me oh thank you
number three finding nemo
marlin a clown fish is overly cautious
with his son nemo who has a
foreshortened fin
when nemo swims too close to the surface
to prove himself he's caught by a diver
and horrified marlin must set out to
find him
a blue reef fish named dory who has a
really short memory joins marlin and
complicates the encounters with sharks
jellyfish and a host of ocean dangers
meanwhile nemo plots his escape from a
dentist's fish tank starring albert
brooks ellen degeneres alexander gould
and directed by andrew stanton critics
say breathtakingly lovely and grounded
by the stellar efforts of a well-chosen
cast finding nemo as another beautifully
crafted gem to pixar's crown and taught
us how to speak whale
[Music]
what are you doing
are you sure you speak whale can you
[Music]
you're speaking like upset stomach maybe
i should try humpbacks no don't try
humpback
all right whoa it actually sounds sick
maybe louder huh
don't
do that too much orca didn't that sound
a little orchestra it doesn't sound orca
it sounds like nothing i've ever heard
just as well he might be hungry don't
worry whales don't eat clown fish they
eat krill run away
oh look grill
number two toy story
woody a good-hearted cowboy doll who
belongs to a young boy named andy sees
his position as andy's favorite toy
jeopardized when his parents buy him a
buzz lightyear action figure
even worse the arrogant buzz thinks he's
a real spaceman on a mission to return
to his home planet when andy's family
moves to a new house woody and buzz must
escape the clutches of maladjusted
neighbor sid phillips and reunite with
their boy starring tom hanks tim allen
don rickles and directed by john
lasseter critics say entertaining as it
is innovative toy story reinvigorated
animation while heralding the arrival of
pixar as a family-friendly force to be
reckoned with it also totally saved our
lives and we are eternally grateful
who's in charge here
the claws our master claw chooses who
will go and who will stay this is
ludicrous hey bozo you got a brain
[Music]
oh no
sid
get down
[Music]
i have been
chosen farewell my friends i go on to a
better place
gotcha
a bus light here
no way
[Music]
[Music]
yes
stop against
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
monsters inc monsters incorporated is
the largest scare factory in the monster
world and james p sullivan is one of its
top scarers sully is a huge intimidating
monster with blue fur large purple spots
and horns his scare assistant best
friend and roommate is mike wazowski a
green opinionated feisty little one-eyed
monster and visiting from the human
world is boo a tiny girl who goes where
no human has ever gone before starring
john goodman billy crystal steve buscemi
and directed by pete doctor critics say
clever funny and delightful to look at
monsters inc delivers another resounding
example of how pixar elevated the bar
for modern all ages animation
we're watching you wazowski always
watching
just the other day someone asked me who
i thought the most beautiful monster was
in all the monstropolis you know what i
said what did you say
i said
sully sully no no no that's not what i
was going to say i mean you're not
making
[Music]
what's good here get out of here you're
ruining everything i went back to get
your paperwork and there was a door what
a door handle was in it wait a minute
randall that cheater he's trying to
boost his numbers or something else what
a clay in the egg bay
what look in the bag
oh
they don't have anything i like here so
take care celia
what's going on celia please try to
understand
i have to
michael
on three one two
soul joe is a middle school band teacher
whose life hasn't quite gone the way he
expected his true passion is jazz and
he's good
but when he travels to another realm to
help someone find their passion he soon
discovers what it means to have soul
starring jamie foxx tina fey felicia
rashad angela bassett and directed by
pete doctor critics say a film is
beautiful to contemplate as it is to
behold soul proves pixar's power to
deliver outstanding all ages
entertainment remains undimmed dr
borgenson will be matched with soul
number 22.
oh we're going to get into this now
excuse me
22 you come out of this dimension right
now how many times have to tell you i
don't want to go to earth stop fighting
and have a look
22 has been at the u seminar for quite
some time and has had such notable
mentors as gandhi abraham lincoln and
mother teresa
i made her cry ignore that
we're truly glad to have you here dr
borginson
[Music]
it is an honor having you prepared 22
for earth i'm gonna make you wish you
never died most people wish that 22.
bye
cars
while traveling to california to race
against the king and chick hicks for the
piston cup championship lightning
mcqueen becomes lost after falling out
of his trailer in a rundown town called
radiator springs while there he slowly
befriends the town's odd residents
including sally doc hudson and mater and
when it comes time for him to leave the
championship is no longer his top
priority starring owen wilson paul
newman bonnie hunt larry the cable guy
and directed by john lasseter critics
say cars offers visual treats that more
than compensate for its somewhat thinly
written story adding up to a satisfying
diversion for young viewers on your mark
get set uno for the morning do i for the
show try to get ready and go after us
the flag means go
remember the fl
here we go
uh doc
what are you doing man
oh dear it would seem i'm off to a poor
start well better late than never
come on mater i might do a little help
uh okay
you got your toe cable well yeah i
always got my toe cable why
oh just in case
[Music]
oh
hey
was that floating like a cadillac or was
that stinging like a beamer i'm confused
and finally our number one pixar film is
toy story 2. woody's stolen from his
home by toy dealer al from al's toy barn
leaving buzz lightyear and the rest of
the gang to try to rescue him but when
woody discovers that he's actually a
valuable collectible from a once popular
television show called woody's roundup
and is reunited with his horse bullseye
jesse the yodeling cowgirl and his
faithful sidekick stinky pete the
prospector he doesn't want to leave
starring tom hanks tim allen joan cusack
and directed by ash brandon john
lasseter and lee unkrich
critics say the rare sequel that
arguably improves on its predecessor toy
story 2 uses inventive storytelling
gorgeous animation and a talented cast
to deliver another rich movie going
experience for all ages and we finally
got to see evil emperor zerg in action
so we meet again buzz lightyear for the
last time
[Music]
he's got an ion blaster
[Music]
the emergency hatch come on
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
come on hurry
but buzz
[Music]
i'll never give in you killed my father
no buzz
i
am your father
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for even more news
scores and recommendations on the tv
shows and movies that you love until
next time i'm your host naz prez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
you